okay so the topic of this video is going
to be neurons and the nervous system and
we're mainly going to focus on how
neurons send messages or signals to
other neurons so let's get started so
when we look at the nervous system you
know like any body system the the
digestive system or the circulatory
system the nervous system is made up of
a collection of organs which are made up
of tissue which are made up of cells it
just so happens that the nervous system
helps to control thoughts movements and
in life processes that that take place
within the body now one thing I want to
mention is that the nervous system
responds fairly quickly to what we call
a stimulus you know light is an example
of a stimulus you know when you shine
light into somebody's eye like you see
in the picture the pupil gets really
really small it's it's trying to prevent
too much light from entering the eye but
in dim light you can see here's the set
hairs and I in dim light you can see the
pupil or the black spot in the middle is
is much more open to try to let what
little light is available into the eye
to help you see but the nervous system
responds quickly but not instantly you
know if you were to stare into
somebody's eyes and turn the lights on a
split moment later you would see the
pupil change shape and so this is
something you can try at home just to
see how quick the nervous system does
respond when you also think about what
must happen in order for this person to
pick up the red apple that's sitting on
the bench well first of all you know you
know that light is made up of ROYGBIV
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet so white light strikes the a poor
and red light reflects into the person's
eyes well the eyes contain what are
called photoreceptors or rods and cones
that's going to send a signal those rods
and cones cells those photoreceptors in
your eyes are going to send an
electrical signal to your brain that
your brain will then receive that signal
and start to
another signal to your hand now what
we're gonna focus on in a few moments is
what is this signal that it sends well
your brain is eventually gonna tell your
hand to reach out and grab the Apple so
the signal travels down the spine the
signal travels down your arm and
eventually to your hand and the muscles
of your hand then react to this signal
and start to reach for the Apple well
you know let's look at neurons neurons
are also known as nerve cells and the
function of neurons or nerve cells is to
transfer these signals to and from the
brain these signals are known as
impulses and so as we get through this
we're gonna see that neurons are made
from three basic parts the cell body
identified in the diagram you know this
is what contains the nucleus and the
majority of the organelles such as
mitochondria vacuoles lysosomes smooth
and rough ER Golgi bodies and coming off
of the cell body like in the picture
here you can see there's several dozen
what are called dendrites and they're
little branches and the function of
dendrites is to receive these signals or
these impulses from a neighboring neuron
so in my animation that flashing yellow
spiky object that's a that's the
electrical signal and so notice how
neurons are in close proximity to other
neurons and so focus on the cell in the
middle the dendrites on the cell in the
middle just received an impulse from the
neighboring cell and ultimately this
this flashing yellow spiky object this
is you know symbolic of our of our
signal here the impulse it's going to
travel down what is called the axon that
long straightaway that you kind of see
in the neuron pictured here well what
happened is when the electrical signal
gets to the axons end well we're gonna
see that in just a little bit what I
want to next mention are the various
types of neurons
you know first of all there are what are
called sensory neurons and like the name
implies these are related to our senses
they detect stimuli and these are the
the neurons that transmit signals to and
from the brain so in our animation here
a woman's hand is coming in contact with
the hot flame well on her hand are our
temperature signals thermo receptors
they're called
and their job is to detect heat in this
case and send a signal to the woman's
brain eventually telling her to pull her
hand away and so our sensory neurons are
directly related to our five senses you
know the sense of sight the sense of
smell sense of hearing our sense of
taste and our sense of touch well we
also have what are a second type of
neurons called inter neurons and the
reason for the picture is because these
are located inside of the brain your
sensory neurons which we just previously
mentioned will detect you know hot and
cold for instance and they will send a
signal to the brain so the inter neurons
actually receive these electrical
signals from the sensory neurons so if
you think of you know detecting the the
woman who was had her hand over the
candle just a moment ago she has sensory
neurons in her hand that will send a
signal to the inter neurons in her brain
and then the inter neurons in her brain
will receive the message and eventually
send another signal back to her hand
saying to pull away from the heat and
then there are what are called the motor
neurons and motor neurons like you see
in this animation are gonna pass this
the signal again the signal is called an
impulse to other tissue in this case the
motor neuron is passing the the
electrical signal two muscle cells
muscle cells are are connected to two
neurons two nerves and when the
electrical signal V the impulse when it
comes in contact with the muscle cells
it causes the muscles to react
by contracting and stretching so if you
think of the woman again touching the
hot candle a moment ago her sensory
neurons touched the hot candle and sent
a message to her inter neurons the inter
neurons will receive that message and
send another signal to her motor neurons
and eventually the motor neurons will
pull the hand away from the hot candle
now I want to focus specifically on how
do Narns send these signals well before
we get into that we need to look at kind
of the environment of a neuron and when
a neuron is at rest and not sending a
signal or an impulse it it's what we
it's in the states known as resting
potential we know let's zoom on into the
cell membrane of this neuron for a
closer look
when we do we see the exterior of the
neuron on top and the interior of the
neuron on the bottom and an electrode we
can actually insert a little tiny
electrode into into the cell to kind of
measure the electrical charge and what
we've learned by doing this is that the
interior of a neuron has a negative
charge because inside of the neuron yes
there's cytoplasm and but the interior
of a neuron is filled with proteins
proteins that the cell needs in its
daily activities well proteins typically
have they have a negative charge to them
and so that's the reason why the
internal charge of a neuron is negative
even though I just had some K pluses
appear in my animation the k+ is
representative of potassium ions that
are also floating around in the interior
but the reason the the inside of the
cell is has a negative charge is just
that the positive potassium czar just
purely outnumbered there's just a lot
more of the negative proteins on the
inside of the neuron so the interior of
a cell is measured in mil
volts and it comes in around a negative
70 millivolts
well we've also measured the exterior
using these electrodes and what we've
learned is that the exterior it has a
positive as a positive charge to it
because outside of the neuron outside of
the cell membrane of the neuron we see a
whole bunch of sodium ions na is the
symbol for sodium and so when we look at
the resting potential or we look at a
neuron that's not sending an impulse
when a neuron is at rest when a neuron
is at rest this is kind of the
environment that that we see the
interior has a negative charge even
though there are some positive potassium
rifting around inside the neuron the
exterior has a positive charge because
of all the sodium's now we're gonna be
focusing our attention a lot on the
sodium's and the potassium I'm gonna in
a few moments I'm gonna remove the
negative proteins just because they're
gonna get in the way and they're just
kind of added clutter to the animations
that follow but just keep in mind that
they're still there so when a neuron is
at rest it has what's called resting
potential but let's say you touch
something hot with your hand well then
the neuron will send a signal and this
is known as an action potential well the
analogy I like to make is that an action
potentials like people doing the wave at
a sporting event one person stands up
and sits down then the next person
stands up in six down then the next
person stands up and sits down and I
hope you'll see why I chose this is a
nice as a nice allergy as analogy as we
move on but the definition of an action
potential it is an action potential is
that impulse is that electrical signal
that we've been talking about and that
electrical signal or the impulse will
move down the length of a neuron down
that long straightaway known as the
accent and so let's talk about how a
neuron generates the impulse in my
animation I have the inside
of the cell just remind yourself that
there's a negative charge even though I
did not draw all the negative proteins
that are typically found inside the cell
just to reduce clutter
I removed the negative proteins that are
found inside the cell and I want you to
focus your attention on the positive
sodium's and the positive potassium so
the interior cell again that has a
negative charge and around negative 40
millivolts watch what happens around
negative 40 millivolts those black
sodium doorways black sodium channels
are gonna open and that's gonna allow
sodium to diffuse into the cell
bringing the normal negative interior up
to a positive charge because again when
all that sodium rushes in because of
diffusion sodium has a positive charge
and it brings the charge up from the
negative range into the positive range
and that's what an impulse is and
impulse is not a physical object that
you can hold in your hand an impulse is
that change from negative to positive
well what happens next is once the
charge reaches a certain strength of
positivity plus 50 millivolts as you see
in the animation it causes the red
potassium doors to open the red
potassium channels to open and then the
potassium will simply diffuse out of the
cell dropping the charge again you got
em keep in mind that when you lose a
bunch of positive potassium when you
lose a bunch of positive charges the
charge is gonna go back down into the
negative range and so again this is what
an action potential is it's the change
from negative to positive back to
negative and eventually the area returns
again back to its negative charge and
this process continues down the entire
length of an axon and I hope you're
gonna see in just a moment why I think
the analogy of people doing the wave at
a sporting event works well let's look
at this next animation so in this case
here's an action
or an impulse moving down a neuron and
as it moves down the axon right now
we're gonna freeze it right here and
let's zoom on in and get a closer look
so again here we have the sodium on the
outside the na and the K or the
potassium on the inside now keep in mind
that normally the inside of the neuron
has a negative charge I simply did not
draw all the negative proteins inside
the neuron because I just didn't want to
add to the clutter I want you to focus
on the sodium and the potassium but just
remember that inside of a neuron there's
a negative charge and so what happens is
the the black sodium channels are gonna
open and that will cause the sodium to
diffuse in that brings this normally
negative charged area into the positive
range that's the impulse and when the
positive charge becomes strong enough it
causes the black sodium doors to shut
and it causes the red potassium doors to
open and once that happens this the the
K or the potassium can exit the cell
dropping the charge back into the
negative range once the charge becomes a
certain negative strength those red
potassium doors will shut and the next
set of black sodium doors will open and
the process repeats it's kind of like a
person at the sporting event doing a
wave person 1 stands up and sits down
and then person 2 stands up and sits
down so now that the sodium channels
have opened the sodium again will rush
in making this normally negative area
positive in charge when it becomes a
certain positive strength the black
sodium doors will shut and the red
potassium doors will open that allows
the potassium to exit and the charge
drops back down under the negative range
it's like again a person doing the wave
standing up and sitting down when the
charge reaches a certain negative
strength
blak potassium excuse me the red
potassium doors shut and the black sewed
the next black sodium door is open and
that causes again the sodium to diffuse
in bringing the charge up to the
positive range once it becomes a certain
strength of positivity the black sodium
channel shut and the red potassium doors
open that causes the potassium to exit
again drop in the charge back into the
negative range
here's another animation that kind of
gives you a more a more a simpler view
but also I think it really shows what we
mean by like the analogy of people doing
a wave as the action potential moves
down the charge spikes into the positive
range and then drops back to negative
almost like a person standing up and
sitting down standing up and sitting
down at a sporting event so every time
the sodium rushes in the charge becomes
positive and every time the potassium
exits it goes back to being negative so
after the impulse is passed you're kind
of left with a big mess and now there's
a problem not even got too much sodium
on the inside of the cell and it doesn't
belong there it's gonna get its it
belongs on the outside of the cell and
we also have too much potassium on the
outside of the cell and it normally is
found on the inside of the cell so
something has to reset the cell back to
its normal environment and that's
something that's gonna clean up the mess
is known as the sodium potassium pump so
who cleans up the mess is what is called
the sodium potassium pump and how does
it happen well through the process of
active transport the use of ATP in my
animation in my animation I have the the
black sodium one two three sodium ions
at a time will enter the sodium
potassium pump and with the help of ATP
when ATP is broken heat is released that
heat causes the sodium potassium pump to
change shapes and therefore pump out the
sodium that originally diffused into the
cell well it's called the sodium
potassium pump because potassium one two
potassium ions at a time are then pumped
back into the cell so when does this
happen this happens after the impulse
has passed where is the sodium potassium
pump located well it's located in the
cell membrane but most importantly why
is this relevant well this has to happen
in order to restore the cell back to its
normal resting potential that way the
cell can be ready to send another
impulse in the future if needed so here
here is our animation as we left it and
now I added the blue sodium potassium
pumps and again three sodium ions at a
time will be released and two potassium
ions at a time will be returned now if
you imagine all the sodium potassium
pumps working at the same time the cell
can be returned to its normal condition
in quite some time so imagine that all
six the blue sodium potassium pumps and
just got done doing their job there you
go the Sal will be back to its normal
negative condition in a relatively short
amount of time so now that we have
zoomed back out to these two neurons
let's continue the movement of the
impulse or the action potential and now
that the impulse has reached the end of
the neuron on the left let's zoom on in
for a closer look now what we're seeing
here is the little gap in between the
two neurons known as the synapse there's
a real small microscopic gap in between
the the neuron on the left and the
neuron on the right and this small
little gap here
presents us with a problem well let's
see sodium comes in and potassium comes
out so we see the the impulse again is
moving sodium comes in and potassium
comes out and one more time sodium comes
in there is the impulse again and now
notice how the impulse has nowhere left
to go it's reached the end of the neuron
on the left and this synapse this gap
represents a problem because the impulse
can't cross this gap again the impulse
is just this change of positive and
negative electrical charges but there is
a solution neurons contain proteins by
the name of neurotransmitters the SAU on
the left in a moment is going to release
neurotransmitter proteins to the cell on
the right and so what we see in the in
in this process here is that the impulse
has reached the end or the terminal of
the cell on the left the neuron on the
left so the impulse has nowhere left to
go its reach the terminal end well what
happens next is you can see that there
are three vesicles in the cell to the
left and a vesicle has just fused with
the cell membrane and is slowly
releasing the black neurotransmitters
which simply diffuse across that gap
across the synapse and notice how one of
them landed on a receptor to the neuron
on the right okay so the receptor will
catch these neurotransmitter proteins
and what it kind of happens next is
pretty neat when it catches the
neurotransmitters that was so now that
the receptor on the neuron to the right
just captured a neurotransmitter that
will stimulate the first round of sodium
channels to open once that happens
sodium diffuses in that brings the
charge up to the positive range a new
impulse has been created and eventually
the potassium channel will open and
potassium will exit that will drop the
charge into the negative range that
causes the net
sodium channel to open and then sodium
will diffuse in bringing the charge up
into the positive range that will cause
the red potassium channel to open and
potassium exits it's a new action
potential it's a new impulse and so the
process simply continues like we said a
moment ago sodium rushes in it creates a
positive charge in an area that is
normally negative and that will cause
the the potassium doorways to open so
potassium can exit the next round of
sodium channels were open and sodium
will diffuse in creating the positive
charge that will cause the next set of
potassium doors to open and potassium to
exit and then that will cause the next
round of sodium channels to open
creating an impulse again which will
then cause the Potala the potassium
channels to open and potassium exits so
again what we saw here is how an impulse
can be triggered in a brand new cell and
again now we're coming to the end of the
second neuron here so the impulse
reaches the terminal end sodium rushes
in the charge becomes positive potassium
exits sodium rushes in the charge
becomes positive potassium exits sodium
rushes in the charge becomes positive
and now notice how again the impulse has
nowhere left to go so the sound on the
left will now release its supply of
neurotransmitters so the vesicle will
fuse with the cell membrane and slowly
release neurotransmitters the
neurotransmitters attached themselves to
a receptor on the cell on the right that
stimulates the creation of a new impulse
a sodium channel opens sodium rushes in
potassium exits and then that causes the
next sodium channel to open soda
rushes in and that causes the potassium
channels to open allowing potassium to
exit and so let's say you want to kick a
soccer ball you're looking at the soccer
ball with your eyes and your brain is
about to tell your feet to kick a soccer
ball well how does this work well your
brain will send an impulse down one
neuron which will release
neurotransmitters to the next neuron the
second neuron will receive the
neurotransmitters and create its own
impulse the impulse reaches the end of
cell number two so number two will
release its own neurotransmitters which
will create an impulse for cell number
three cell number three now that the
impulse has reached the end of cell
number three saw number three will
release its own neurotransmitters and
cell number four will create an impulse
the impulse reaches the end of cell
number four releases neurotransmitters
which arrive at cell number five now in
reality this process of course happens
much much faster where to slowing it
down to talk through it and eventually
the impulse reaches the muscles of your
foot and when the impulse when the
electrical charge
comes in contact with muscles the
electrical charge causes the muscles of
the foot to stretch and contract in a
very coordinated manner allowing you to
hopefully successfully strike the soccer
ball and perhaps score goal now keep in
mind when we're young we're not very
coordinated at our muscle movements but
as we age and and just more experienced
we become much more coordinated and so
there you go there's the end of these
notes I hope you see why I think an
action potentials kind of like people
doing a wave one person stands and sit
kind of like the charge going to the
positive range and then into the
negative range so go ahead and pause
this video if you're in my biology class
try to answer these questions and I'd be
happy to check your answers before
school or after school good luck